It was a thing on our reality sandwich worked.
I was criticizing the salt stoned ape theory and it was only based on one point,
the visual acuity point.
They were arguing about Roland Fischer's work on visual acuity being measurably
improved by who knows?
You could try that.
I looked that up.
I can find that study.
Yeah,
I didn't find it either.
Maybe that's wrong,
but it's still like to chart harp on one.
Okay.
Fairly insignificant portion of the theory.
The theory never made sense to me in that regard.
The,
the visual acuity thing,
because that's in low doses.
That's what you're saying.
But they're not eating low doses.
They're eating a lot of that shit.
Why low doses if they could find it,
you know,
they're,
they're eating probably tons of it.
We talked to,
we talked to our primatologists about it and he said that the time period that
Mckenna has using does not work for the way he understands,
uh,
climate,
the growth of the neo cortex and predominance apparently.
Um,
so his theory about the massive expansion of our brains,
right.
Did it happen way before Mckenna says the stoned ape theory or what's happening.
But then he might've been confused about that time period cause they,
I believe Macanta mine at candidate know Mckenna says that early plasticine
error I think.
And like,
sorry,
I don't know.
Well the theory for the folks who don't know what the fuck are they is,
the theory is that at one point in time monkeys climb down from the trees and
they were experimenting with new food sources and they started eating suicide as
mushrooms because there was these great herds of Unpeel it cattle that were,
you know,
hooked cattle that are wandering around the fields dropping shits and that these
mushrooms grow from these shits and these,
these,
uh,
monkeys and baboons have been dead.
They've demonstrated them lifting up cow patties and looking for bugs and stuff
on that you think cause it's all moist and,
and that eating these mushrooms that grew on these,
these cow shits made them more,
more evolved and made them,
uh,
like doubled the size of the human brain may have them develop language.
Yeah.
Look,
something happened.
Sure.
Look at us.
And look at them.
It's pretty fucking clear.
Is that a big Goddamn gap?
Why?
What is this gap?
I know.
I really think it's that crazy,
a crazy idea and you know,
most people I talk to you,
they were,
their main response scientists gave was like,
you know you need a time machine.
It really proved that theory.
So yeah,
don't get your eyes.
See this gentleman,
one of the greatest podcast cast,
if not the greatest
all time flows.
I don't have an ax.
Okay.
That's the problem I was worried about.
I am sure I was worried about you being a little too trendy.
It's fun cop breath stretching.
You don't have that ordered.
I worked out with Steve Maxwell and Toronto and I ordered an Indian club bells.
There were this big iron baseball bats and you're like,
oh
the barely do it.
10 pounds,
man.
It's crazy.
It's a crazy exercise.
So I ordered these 15 pounders and I'm going to build up to 45 pounders.
That's when you're a fucking real ox.
When you're a real animal and you want to put the squeezed off.
No,
I've been out for almost two months now.
The back injury?
Yeah.
I had a reoccurring thing where I would pop out a rib head.
So what I decided to do is just work out a lot of it,
do a lot of cardio,
a lot of hitting the bag and stuff.
Actually I got leaner and um,
uh,
less uh,
less rolling and more like high rep kettlebell stuff and a lot,
a lot of like different strength and conditioning shit cause I,
this,
this injury kept happening.
It can't,
I,
it happened over a course of a few months over and over again in the same spot.
I was like,
all right,
I need to get in this thing.
Some actual real time off or it's going to be crying.
You got no guy like you and your physique.
You don't really have to worry about that crest scratch.
We'll have
the um,
the dance dance or video you did and it was,
it called,
oh Steve,
what the fuck?
There's a self defense vouch with crepey.
You had no,
you hadn't like,
uh,
fuck,
not unintentional unintentional dancer.
You had a sketch.
The Creator,
was it called?
Oh yeah,
I was,
I've buck on and on.
It's not unintentional orthodox stance.
Answer.
Yes.
Well,
it was that.
I just did the weirdest shit where I'd show up in like underwear and get mask.
I had one of those Bob's thing and I just come it,
Bam and I hit it and go run and go,
hey,
that's some shit.
He was like the most absurd shit that ever done.
He's helped me.
I think I might have it in my trunk.
I might.
He gave me a DVD.
We were,
we were hanging out.
He goes,
this thing has fucking thing.
I did this.
Go check this out.
Tell me like it.
I get home.
I just talking about computer to run.
The fuck is wrong with this deal.
I get such a good
pink socks and shit
fly by but then run away.
That was so fucking retarded.
Alex Jones,
the Joey d is on the Alex Jones show.
Have you ever seen that?
For those who haven't seen it,
so we might as well just stick this in here,
put it in or you got to see this.
Well,
we'll edit it in here.
This is the funniest thing that I've already,
so there's a segment off of the uh,
Austin,
uh,
video that Brian made when we went to Austin with little year.
Funniest thing that I've ever seen in my life were in doom and gloom.
Alex Jones,
no
black helicopters and aliens.
The government,
the CIA.
Eugenics is a master race.
It's that layer.
He's all crazy like this.
And Joey dance comes in with a story about some my little weed under his balls
and Alex is trying to stop him from saying on the air,
but Joey just runs with it.
And it is the single most powerful performance you've ever seen in your life.
The commitment he has on a fucking national right way,
not right wing sort of libertarian,
crazy apocalyptic radio show.
This guy wants to talk about,
we ain't go ablations,
gentlemen.
Right now.
The price of gold is down all time lows and the neo cons for starting this up.
No,
he'll tell you about fucking,
and he'll sell you for freeze dried food that you keep on going because it
survives nuclear war.
It's in special aluminum cans and Joanie is talking about smuggling weed under
his balls and it's the funniest fucking thing I've ever seen in my life.
It's a humbling can I?
Where can I get it?
It's not book.
Put It on this and we'll say like,
I got to see that.
Boom.
Schelok log.
I hadn't heard back yet.
I put into my left side.
We're not telling the story
whole bottle right now.
This is freedom.
This is not a control.
There's hope thumping joints worse.
Hold on.
He is worse than problem.
I love him.
But y'all bring this monster
so
you know if people are looking for the truth on this show is about the truth.
I I,
I got debt and I had baggy clothes on but I had a belt on and they sound because
you have baggy clothes on.
They didn't know as well.
Spray pounds.
They said we're going to put you to the x ray machine.
I'm standing there sweating bullets with this baggy under my fucking God left us
bigger than the right regular cause I'm a righty stop.
People don't know that.
I thought I had cancer for couple weeks.
You know the opposite hand.
When my legs open it,
you're like Rodney Dangerfield said,
stop talking about that was sticking up a storm and not to make it my boss.
I'm sweating,
but I
shook my hand.
I'm like,
Mike,
payers are hard at work.
Don't know.
I know.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You come on.
Hold on one second.
Joey Diaz.
Facebook,
Twitter.
Check yourself before you wreck yourself.
Big Dixon.
Yes.
They black cause that's the most important.
Ah,
okay.
Okay.
Tell us for a while been talking
old school comedy store veteran.
Steven is easy.
I know Steve Forever.
Back in the day.
Oh,
California.
You guys have the same car.
Did you?
Gay Lords I bought a couple of weeks ago.
What'd he say?
Let's explore.
Oh,
that's an explorer.
But they're both for the new explorers is supposed to be a shit.
Fords or a spaceship.
Yeah.
Touch everything.
I put my,
I hit a button,
I go drive home.
Really driving home.
Matt fucking whole thing to call Joe Rogan because Joe Rogan.
What the air to 75 75
wow.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
We're living in the future.
That's it guys.
It's really going down.
That's right.
So,
uh,
um,
have you,
uh,
ever thought about doing your own podcast?
No.
You know what it is.
I have fun doing other people.
I've only done yours twice.
I didn't Marin's I did Ari's did you like doing marathons?
I did like doing married.
I did a really early,
I did it like probably when he,
I don't think he would ask me to do it now.
I did it when he was still like,
he's kind of a bunch of scrubs on that show.
Who would let you on?
Thank you.
You wouldn't be the only one that's going to fucking listed,
but way more advanced here on the actual show.
But it's uh,
I enjoy doing them.
I don't really know.
I don't really,
I know it's like,
I like,
I like hanging out with my friends.
It's an awesome tool for pumping up shows though,
man.
It really is.
People will say to me,
you've got to do Joe Rogan's podcast.
I will.
Yeah.
I want to do Benson's too.
Yeah,
this is great too.
But I mean,
as far as like for promoting gigs,
it's,
it makes a huge difference,
man.
If you had your own,
you would really developed,
do you have like a serious website?
Not really.
Now give him a message board.
No.
You should get those yeses.
Yeah.
You develop a little community,
man.
I got a message board that has almost 4 million posts on it,
more than 4 million.
Right?
4 million posts on it.
All these members and you can communicate back and forth with these people.
So easy.
You could promote gig.
I mean,
it's not like anything in the past.
They're your access to your fans.
It's like directly did I feel I answered tweets and I answered like the
intelligent ones and then Facebook messages and stuff and then some stuff on my
website.
But yeah,
I dunno.
Maybe I've never been good at the marketing side.
Yeah,
but this is the best way because it's fun.
Everything else we've done,
it's like,
wow,
I've got to fucking promote on [inaudible].
Gotta do this.
You've got to do that.
Everything else has been like work,
but this does not seem like work at all.
This is like fun stuff.
Yeah,
we should do it,
man.
See rosacea.
You can do it with Brian.
Brian Red Bat.
It's Ryan has its own broadcast network.
Dude.
He could immediately get you seen by hundreds of thousands of people.
Do you have to have an angle?
You have to have an angle.
You can just go get we did today.
We didn't talk about what we're going to do and I don't ever talk about what I'm
going to do.
I mean every now and then someone will be talking about some shit in the
kitchen.
I'm like,
save it,
save it.
Yeah.
No.
Cool.
That's all I got
here we are alive and Sunny California with the movie.
Super High.
Me Star
giving way to describe me.
That's you dude.
I like,
is it like wandering around this life known everywhere you go as not just a
stoner but a super stoner?
It's pretty great.
It's fun.
You know,
most people leave me alone,
but you know,
the people that know,
they're,
uh,
they're usually pretty friendly about it.
You get,
you get it.
I'm a,
yeah,
you're another above me as far as light,
as far as pacos part goes to me and started talking to me about fear factor or
UFC.
Yeah,
it's all pot.
We do
lots of podcasts,
listeners and you know,
and my podcast all about movies.
So,
uh,
you know,
people want to talk to you about movies,
so that's a nice change of pace.
Could you live anywhere that didn't have,
we'd like California has now,
isn't that like a prerequisite?
Like if you thought about moving to some other parts of the country,
like when I moved to Colorado and one of the first things I thought I was like,
okay,
and Colorado's got medical potlucks.
Who was like,
they're,
oh,
it's just like yell.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Well,
that's the thing is all the places that I gravitate towards on the road are
either places where the whole state has medical or a particular city is cooler
than other cities,
you know,
so like it's more decriminalized in some places than others.
And those tend to be the same cities.
I enjoy performing it.
And you're like,
Austin,
Texas is a great example of like some places around there.
I'd be in pretty,
you know,
I'd have to be pretty paranoid about my behavior,
but in Austin you can sort of get away with,
um,
I know you're doing Ann Arbor,
Michigan,
right?
I love that place.
Yeah,
that place is awesome.
That's a place where you wouldn't realize,
he would know bash,
bash for years before Michigan.
And the medical,
and I think also in was probably the reason why medical got over the hump and
Michigan because there so into it.
And that one city,
have you ever seen the four 20 day in Boulder?
Fucking incredible.
They go on the collar on the,
uh,
University of Colorado.
They go on the campus and everyone smokes out like the whole campus.
Like there's clouds of smoke.
I'll give,
never seen anything black.
A thousands of people passing joints around.
It's fucking nuts.
Yeah.
If you ever done an amazing,
no,
I haven't ever been there.
I'm always off somewhere doing a show is I get a good crowd on four 20 we need
you and I need to do a fucking show there next for 20 April 20th in boulder or
don't you do a thing doe commit me on camera every April 20th thought you'd do a
thing where you record a new CD.
That's a,
that's what I tried to do.
Yeah.
This year I was in Sacramento at such a great we town and it was fun to do it
like,
you know,
record a record standing in front of the Capitol building that they have drawn
there on the wall at the punchline in Sacramento.
So it was pretty fun.
So you already have coming out later this year.
But that's what I do is every year.
Like,
you know,
there's a few cities I'm considering for a,
for next year,
but it's just like,
it's a great knife.
We are recording an album.
It's a great way for me to always know you,
you know,
people say for 20 to me so much that it's always top of mine.
So like I know that like right now I know I've got like 11 months to get the,
you know,
the next material ready to go for another album.
And so I'll start ditching the stuff from this album and replacing it with newer
stuff.
But you know,
it's a whole cycle that I go through that seems to be working.
So no boulders show bitches.
No,
but I definitely want to boulder event.
I'm definitely working on,
um,
I think I'm going to go do a show in boulder in,
in uh,
September because that is a great place to go and I've never done up there.
I lived there,
but I never ever performed there.
I think when I was living there I was like,
I don't think I should be doing standup where I live.
It's a little town.
Went a hundred thousand people.
Yeah,
they got a couple of,
they've got a couple of little theaters,
a nice sized theaters in downtown boulder.
Awesome,
awesome town.
One of those rare towns,
the guy that said it best to work for the local paper said it's a working
utopia.
It's one of the few.
It's like,
it's like a weird,
crazy Whoville town,
you know,
it's got the nicest whole foods I've ever been in.
Foods are usually pretty awesome.
So this one's like,
wow to Norris has a restaurant inside of it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
So friendly there.
It's like one of the friendliest places I've ever been.
And they're all living like an asshole in this majestic mountain range.
I mean,
it's all swollen.
Weed is only thing things going on there.
Yeah,
it's cool.
And wait,
that's all you need.
Education and marijuana.
That's a,
that's going to lead to a nice place to be.
Dot.
Benson,
ladies and gentlemen,
no wiser words have ever been spoken.
That's pretty much,
it's like wine and cheese.
Now look at it.
Marie.
Look.
Asshole liquid.
Well,
let me look at this.
And
what do you think that is,
Sarah?
Well read,
man.
I thought I liked you.